insomma richiede molto tempo questa è
tantissimo bene va bene anch'io ti trovi
anche belli questi cappelli dettagliati
verso allora in realtà io ho tagliato
proprio due giorni prima dell'ultima
volta che ci siamo visti erano otto mesi
fa ora che allora no aspetta
innanzitutto stai benissimo comunque non
sono bellissimi
poi volevo dirti che ho visto tutorial
giusto l'altro ieri di una delle fiale
crescentine sono quelle che ci hanno
provato e non crescono non crescono nei
capelli che ho provate tutte
lusaka risolve cameron cresca perché gli
amici era gli alita merda che belli tuoi
capelli posso di certo che belli che
boccolosi che soffici che volume vorrei
tanto averli anch'io così ma vai lì
vorrei come i tuoi essere troppo
voluminosi ne ho troppi capito mi
sveglio al mattino e san rufo no bel no
tu devi proprio fare zitta non ti puoi
permettere di la mente ha chiesto da
bere quando cioè di una davanti centri
spa di testa che ha pagato fior fior di
euro
spero che un po di volume sono da tanti
dal parrucchiere di belen niente niente
nei capelli rimangono così e quindi tu
devi stare soltanto zitto e portare
rispetto
basta mi sono stufata di avere i capelli
davanti costituite in di nemi ne
oscurano la vista quindi proviamo con
delle forcine a vedere qual è il
risultato secondo me molto carino
una esattamente qui perfetto e l'altra
qui top ma come ci sono finite quale for
cinema o non ci posso credere
no adesso me la devo rimettere questa
questa è una guerra
[Musica]
la mari dimmi la verità usi la piastra
cioè non è possibile che tutti abbiamo
restituisci io non capisco perché siete
tutti convinti che usi la piastra no
sono i miei capelli cioè io mi sveglio
al mattino mi butto in doccia esco mi
passò al fondo io così alla casa di mook
appiccicati al viso e devo farmi capelli
ma beata te che fortuna che fortuna poi
di quello che subisco io tutti i giorni
tu li hai ricci se un giorno ti svegli
di voi lisci che passino piastra e
invece no se io li vogliono ricci non
posso non posso solo destinato a veri
capelli ricci perché qualsiasi piegano
mi tiene mi scende quindi io credo in te
credo in noi capelli miei perché oggi
sarete riccissimi perché dovete volerlo
voi per primi
no no stiamo iniziando male vi prego vi
prego
va bene sia grazie mille ci vediamo
sabato ciao ciao ciao guarda ti faccio
una foto mentre sta imparando il
telefono carina no bella ce stai
scherzando
perché questo sono io ci ho le orecchie
così fuori sembra regola sembra un elfo
faccio schifo che cancella
immediatamente questo schifo ma io cosa
devo fare con questi doppi miss colore
che pure pure sta disgrazie mari ma
ascolta ma com'è che hai tutti sti
prodotti per i capelli ricci sulla
perché ci sai perché perché sono una
stupida perché ogni volta penso che
magari comprando un prodotto per i
capelli ricci i miei capelli non dico
che diventino ricci ma almeno un po più
voluminoso invece niente
le ho provate tutte inutile inutile
speso un sacco di soldi ma i miei
capelli tanto non si riceveranno amari
ma non funziona così
ma tu se glieli citera lisci quasi sono
per i vizi
grazie mille per ricordarmelo adesso
sparisce portati dietro tutti quei
prodotti che tanto non mi serviranno mai
a niente
ok come faccio i capelli oggi
[Musica]
lisci sicuramente lisci
però magari posso provare una riga di
lato così per cambiare ma vediamo
oddio sono tutti elettrici o di hokuto
fatto loro con calma vediamo dove si
apre naturalmente naturalmente si apre e
mezzo vabbè dai o una fortuna mi sveglio
io già perfettamente lisci come è sempre
come tutti i giorni della mia vita
sarò sempre bettina quanto tempo
avantissimo questa è male
a chi torna l'annuale guardando